well good evening and welcome to a
special edition of Piers Morgan
uncensored Professor Neil deGrasse Tyson
one on one
in a world where politicians can't
answer questions like what is a woman we
need more people like Neil deGrasse
Tyson he's a man with the answers to the
toughest questions on the planet and the
toughest questions about the planets
what would happen if the Earth stopped
rotating for a second oh yeah that would
be disastrous my day is the boss of the
world famous Hayden planetarium in New
York by night he's the Stargazer
Superstar a familiar face on America's
top talk shows please welcome our friend
Neil deGrasse Tyson is over here
make cameos and everything from The Big
Bang Theory the guy you were telling me
about oh yeah Family Guy mean-spirited
Thoughts From The Stars can take
thousands or even millions of years to
reach the Earth and it startled podcast
is an unlikely Smash Hit infrared can
actually appear into gas clouds and his
best-selling books of course like
astrophysics for people in a hurry have
made him a household name renowned for
demystifying the Milky Way well tonight
the most powerful nerd of the universe
answers the 10 burning questions about
the universe and much more Neil deGrasse
Tyson is uncensored
and Neil deGrasse Tyson joins me now
live well intros don't get better than
that Neil
no no come on I now have to live up to
that introduction you know you put
pressure on me here somebody who went
into this just to be an astrophysicist
uh and you've ended up being a rock star
astrophysicist let me start with that do
you like the fame that comes with this
or do you accept this just go through
the territory
yeah I don't uh I don't have feelings
about it I really what I want to do is
go back to the lab uh once I know others
are on this landscape of sort of public
discourse of Science and I'm a backup
sneak into the lab and then you won't
even know I'm missing and I can do
science again the way this all occurred
was no there I was people would you know
the news folks like you or others would
need a sound bite because some Cosmic
phenomenon or event would take place and
so you go to your local planetarium or
whoever who has some expertise so I was
called early on and they said oh tell us
about this new planet or Pluto and I'd
give him a couple of lines and they
liked it and then they came back for
more and but I remembered distinctly the
first exoplanet 1995 it was NBC news
they sent an action camera to the Hayden
planetarium you know the the the van
with action cam van to the Planetarium
and I gave my best professorial
explanation for how you discover
exoplanets where they they orbit their
host star and they host star Jiggles in
response to the or to the to the gravity
and I talked about the Spectra again but
I looked that evening
the only thing that ended up on on the
news was me doing this with my body I
said okay he didn't come for the lecture
that came for a sound bite and so I so I
went home and I practiced sound bites
because if that's what you want why
don't I give that to you and so I just
took random words from the universe
black hole Quasar Saturn uh Pluto stars
and I came up with two or three
sentences that would be informative make
you smile you know you want to enjoy the
learning and then make you want to come
back for more and then when I started
doing that then floodgates opened and I
then I started showing up on
documentaries
and uh people wanted me to be a
correspondent for their new service
which of course I didn't agree to but
that desire was there and I said to
myself wait a minute
science people like science if it's
packaged in a way that they can see and
feel and embrace and come to want more
so I just kept doing it and then I ended
up getting invited to make cameos and
first run films I was in Batman versus
Superman in a short roll because I'm not
an actor
um but by the way I don't mean to brag
but I was also in Sharknado 6. okay
[Laughter]
okay but yeah I think I got overlooked
by the academy that year
the first of what I wanted to say I
wanted to get you back on for a longer
interview because you very kindly came
in to my studio a couple of months ago
and the segment we did about when's the
world going to end blew up and it's
become one of our most watched segments
that we've done in the in the show's
entirety since we launched back in April
so I wanted to get you back on because
clearly there's a huge public hunger for
information that you provide I'm curious
about this part of it which is your new
book Starry Messenger Cosmic
perspectives on civilization I loved the
way it was described here
Starry Messenger is a wake-up call to
civilization people no longer know who
or what to trust we sow hatred of others
fueled by what we think is true or what
we want to be true without regard to
what is true cultural and political
factions battle for the souls of
communities and of Nations we've lost
all side of what distinguishes facts
from opinions we log grenades at one
another when we could be sharing beers
in pubs I wanted to cheer from the
rooftops when I read that because it's
so important I think to now have this
proper debate because I often talk about
you know 2 000 years ago when we lived
in tribes where everyone in the tribe
dressed the same it's about the same had
the same mentality same attitudes you
know ate the same food and so on and
then slowly we edged out and we met
other tribes who look different behave
differently thought differently and and
both tribes concluded the only way to
deal with this was to kill each other
and it strikes me the social media now
in particular Twitter especially has
almost you know degraded back to 2000
years ago to the tribal world that we
lived in there where the only answer to
anyone that was different to us or
thought differently was to kill them
it appears that's a very insightful
observation of the regressive forces
that social media broadly but definitely
Twitter brings to Modern civilization I
would call it a cesspool really and to
couch it in the way you did I think
unpacks it and reveals sort of the core
forces operating I I remembered the day
when you were able to express an opinion
and someone would say oh that's
interesting well here's my opinion what
do you think of that and then you'd
actually have a conversation about
opinions if you put any opinion on
social media especially Twitter you will
get attacked because that opinion does
not agree with that of the attacker and
I'm thinking to myself that is not how
you advance culture or civilization or
anything and yeah it's highly it's a
highly regressive force and it's
unfortunate I I I'm sad one of the one
of the worst aspects of it actually is
the is the war on science
now science it always seems to me is
almost a perfect personification of what
you've just been talking about because
what scientists do is they try and
establish facts and when facts change
through the scientific work scientists
change their opinions and yet when you
see that happening for example in a
pandemic with a novel a new coronavirus
like covet 19. when you had a scientist
like Anthony fauci for example very
eminent in his field when you have
someone like that who becomes Public
Enemy Number One to large sways of
America and indeed around the world
because he is changing his mind based on
new information it seems to me that that
is putting science itself under attack
yeah so par so part of the problem here
is people don't fully know or understand
what science is or how and why it works
and you also have a gap between people
who are professional scientists and how
they communicate what they do to those
who are not let me just say what fauci
should have done easy very easy to be
you know Monday Morning Quarterback or
or whatever the phrases are that refer
to the hindsight of wisdom uh what he
should have done which says
here is our advice based on the research
that has accumulated thus far right and
as that research continues to come in we
may make adjustments to the advice we're
giving you now stay tuned
that's how that should have been
presented at the beginning but we lived
in a society where everyone is waiting
for the Commandment up from on high and
then then it comes out and then you do
it and then if it changes then you lose
all hope or or trust in what is true and
what is not the same to me with Dr fauci
assumed to me was it he he would say
things like you know the masks are not
that efficient for covid-19 which was
his initial position about what uh and
then it should have said was I know he
should have said our current
understanding of the propagation of this
of this virus tells us that mass are not
as important as washing your hands or
whatever
the rules that came out right so if I've
been to finish it so you've actually
what then happens is Twitter keeps that
clip and then when he changes his
assessment based on new science Twitter
goes wow she's making up as he goes
along he's now saying the complete
opposite and all the conspiracy
theorists who think that this is some
sort of government plot and so on to
control the minds of the people they all
go well there you go look there you go
and actually I just want I mean as a
scientist I must be incredibly
frustrating because it sort of then puts
all science into this world where people
say well how can we believe a word they
say these people
it's frustrating on both sides and like
like both sides of that equation when I
see a scientific discoveries or
knowledge communicated without being
properly couched in what is the degree
of our understanding of what is being
conveyed then I see people who want to
presume that there is this only one
understanding that will never change and
it just sort of ossifies in place and
then when they see a change it somehow
undermines their entire confidence in
the in the in the industry in the in the
entire branch of what it is to do
science in a nation and it's it's
unfortunate so I think you can fix some
of this going back through kindergarten
through 12th grade where every science
class has a part of it where you learn
what it means to ask questions what it
means when you have the moving Frontier
of science that is influenced by new
data and new understandings and new
interpretations and and especially when
there's a novel virus that comes around
you don't have 30 years of data on it so
we all should have participated in that
moving Frontier of Discovery and it all
just became mudslinging it seemed to me
uh Neil that I when this was all
happening in the pandemic I took quite
firm views throughout it like a lot of
people I guess
um one of which was when it was believed
when the vaccines first came along that
they would stop transmission it seemed
to me if you refuse to be vaccinated you
shouldn't be entitled to the same rights
to go to nightclubs and stuff as those
who've taken the vaccine and were
therefore not able to transmit it
however
when it was established that vaccines
actually didn't stop transmission they
just stopped a lot of people getting
very sick of dying the argument to then
suppress any Liberties or freedoms of
the unvaccinated to me it went away
because in that instance if the if the
ability to pass it on is pretty well the
same whether you've been jammed or not
then really it's down to the individual
if they want to protect themselves from
from this virus so I changed my mind I
got pilloried when I said my original
statement I got pilloried when I changed
my mind I got billeried like everybody
in this pandemic about all of it and yet
to me it seemed perfectly logical
honestly to to just change my mind
because that's changed
yes and and so like I said it's a
societal problem where we need to train
ourselves to understand what it means to
eavesdrop or participate on the moving
Frontier of scientific discovery by the
way that's a very different place
textually informationally from the parts
of the scientific Enterprise that have
been multiply verified by scientific
observations and experiments those facts
are objectively true whether or not you
believe in them and so you get people on
the frontier seeing the ping pong match
in of information and then they take
that same uncertainty and bring it to
the core of what it is that has built
this civilization that's the
understanding of how the chemistry
physics and biology of nature works so
yeah we need to be re uh
we need to revamp the science curriculum
so that when you become an adult you
don't behave uh
you don't behave like a child right and
that's I don't know any other way to say
it I think there's perfectly well well
put actually and I want to take a short
break when we come back I want to talk
to you the book claims astrophysics can
teach us about every aspect of society
including War politics religion truth
beauty gender and race we're going to go
through all of those Neil deGrasse Tyson
and see how you're going to fix the
world well welcome back I'm still here
with astrophysicist and author Neil
deGrasse Tyson for a one-hour special at
Piers Morgan uncensored um Professor you
you in the book very it's it's a
fascinating read this but it's about how
we sort of recast I guess major social
debates of our age using the cosmos
astrophysics as a way to do this and and
there are various uh headings that you
go through I want to go through these
one by one they're obviously huge issues
each one of them but I'm curious if you
can just go through them and explain to
me what you mean so take War for example
right now we have a war in Europe which
I didn't think I'd see again in my
lifetime how can
astrophysics or the cosmos how can that
help us to understand Warfare and to
deal with trying to avoid Warfare
so let me let me couch it a little
differently yes there is explicit
science we can learn by studying the
universe that can be directly applied to
activities and conflicts here on Earth
but more broadly it's a scientific world
view that informs how you ask questions
how you resolve disputes and which is
why scientists are some of the most
collaborative people of any branch of
what we do in Civilization uh you might
remember a year ago or so there was the
banner headlines of the first black hole
ever photographed and he said wow okay
but then you you unpack that and you
realize there's like thousand scientists
in a hundred observatories that
collaborated to obtain that photo and
you say well how do you do that you know
what happens if you do that in the U.N
everybody's fighting each other and
throwing their shoe at each other so so
there's there's certain ethos
when two scientists argue we know
there's an Unwritten rule that either
I'm right and you're wrong you're right
and I'm wrong or we're both wrong so the
argument isn't to harm the other person
the argument is to explore ways to
ultimately agree and maybe we need more
data what do we do then what do we do
though in an era of disinformation that
is promoted aggressively through the
internet and I'm talking specifically
for example Vladimir Putin's propaganda
to the Russian people that actually what
he's doing in Ukraine is a special
operation to remove Nazis from a country
that is actually run by a Jewish
president and of course the irony being
it is the Russians who are behaving
actually like Nazis and what they're
doing there but this mythology which
he's pumping to the Russian people
morning noon and night then blows around
the internet and a lot of people around
the world start to buy in to this
completely false narrative so how does
science help when you have that kind of
active aggressive disinformation
so in the in the chapter truth and
Beauty I spent a fair amount of time
evaluating what the meaning of Truth is
especially as different people interpret
it and one branch of that would be a
personal truth let's say and this is
like let's say Jesus is your savior
right in a free country where we have
freedom of religious expression uh no
one's going to take that from you that's
a personal truth but if you want to have
other people agree with that truth and
they might have a different savior or a
different religious tradition then it
will require some serious Act of
persuasion but in the limit as we've
seen in the history of civilization
outright Warfare and bloodshed and death
so in a pluralistic society your
personal truths really need to be kept
to yourself or casually attempting to
influence others but then there's
another kind of Truth which our brain is
susceptible to
if you repeat something over and over
your brain natively says it must be true
and once you reach that point you lose
all curiosity to unravel whether or not
it isn't true okay you you don't go back
to it you just accept it and what the
internet has done especially social
media has become the world's greatest
propaganda machine if Hitler had access
to the inner to social media no telling
what would happen to the world at the
time all right so so propaganda is one
of these things where someone is trying
to influence you
in a surreptitious way and then you end
up fully agreeing without you even
having consciously done so and that's
dangerous there's a the other kind of
Truth an objective Truth where the
methods and tools of science are
exquisitely tuned to distinguish that
which is true in that which is not and
how does that happen we I just say to
you
here here's some tools use them in
whatever way you can to make sure you
don't conclude that something is true
that is not or that something is not
true that is and when you do that you
are an independent thinker and you're no
longer susceptible to any of that when
you have a leader like Donald Trump who
is you know a very popular in divisive
and equal measure as president of the
United States but when he could look at
the sky when it was blue and say it's
gray
and a lot of his supporters would then
think it's gray because he had such a
hold over them how dangerous is that
yeah so what happens is if you're in a
democracy if the electorate
you in a democracy you expect there some
power of sway
that is given to those with personality
all right with Charisma all right
President Kennedy had a bit of a
Charisma about him so you kind of expect
that you even want a little bit of that
not not I I don't have a problem with
this we don't put people into their
presidency based on their resume if we
did half the presidents that were voted
in wouldn't have never become presidents
they're voted in because there's
something about them that you you like
that you like their Panache their
attitude their one of my favorite quotes
from Harry Truman
um just coming out of the second world
war his moniker was give him hell Harry
right and they say uh Mr President why
are you always giving people hell and
you know his response was it was no I
tell them the truth they think it's hell
so he was an uh he was an honest guy so
I think it's okay to be to like someone
on a personal level people said of
George W Bush that you know my my issue
with him was that he couldn't pronounce
the word nuclear yet he had access to
nuclear codes so as a physicist that a
little worrisome but um people said you
can have a you can have a beer with him
and Mike I spent some time a little bit
of time in that bush White House and one
time we made eye contact and I felt like
I'd known him my whole life there was
some extra chemistry there and I see
that and I understand how politicians
can rise because of it but at some point
they cannot be the total source of your
knowledge and your Enlightenment and
your wisdom because you're an individual
and it is especially in the American
documents there's probably at least some
of this in other Western World
democracies but certainly the American
documents it is a government of the
People by the people and for the people
it's our government it's not the
leader's government and we can forget
that after a while we can say I want the
link to make all decisions for me then
what are you that then you're you're yes
you're a follower but it's the leader
who actually should be following you in
a Dem in a democracy even in a republic
where you have someone in someone in
between you and the top dog so it was a
it was a problem that his Cult of
following was so potent
that people would lose sight of what is
true and what is not because they would
just follow whatever he said that's just
at the end of the day dangerous you made
a very good point uh that there are not
many people left alive who probably
remember what it was like to actually
endure Nazism for example uh fascism at
its worst and that because of that when
it comes round again in the way that
we're seeing now in in certain parts of
the world people don't really understand
the danger or how bad it can get very
quickly
I just suggested that that might be a
cause because you like like you just
said
not just signs of it in the United
States but many other parts in the world
they're leaders that are rising up with
their personality
and their their their their their their
Charisma to their followers is bigger
than any analysis of objective truths
that should be behind the decisions that
are getting made and once you control
the public you're electorate at that
level
um then they're putty in your hands
they're they're so I I hate to be so
cynical but the last person a politician
wants
is somebody who can completely think for
themselves
it means they're not susceptible to and
by the way I don't I'm not even blaming
politicians because why do politicians
lie because they're telling us what we
want to hear right because we know if
they told us the truth we wouldn't vote
for them so so politicians I think are a
symptom of the Public's
um of the state of the public not
the other way around
let's take a short break again and by
the way why why are you listen why are
you listening to an astrophysicist say
all this because I study science and how
the world works right and and the the
causes and effects of decisions that are
made and what do they look like
statistically probabilistically how do
you classify ideas how do you test ideas
for whether or not they're going to work
all of that analysis can apply to the
universe and it can apply to everyday
life and that's kind of what drove the
the inspiration of the book right and of
course science should be applied
historically so you can say look we we
can learn from what we did wrong on this
occasion and not do it wrong again but
too often we fall into the I I think it
was an apocryphal Einstein quote
actually but the quote about the
definition of insanity is doing the same
thing over and over again and expecting
a different result
foreign
for sure yeah so so uh so it's a
different world and again as an educator
uh I I try to address the public I try
to address the educational system the
politicians are at the tip of this
Iceberg and people say oh let's get the
Trump haters are saying let's get rid of
trump he's the problem he's in trouble
but wait a minute wasn't it 86 million
Americans voted for him yeah and more
people voted for Trump in 2020 that had
ever voted for anyone in the history of
Elections except that same election with
with Biden so if you remove Trump
they're the there's still the matter of
the 86 million people and what they want
to see as their leader so as an educator
I don't look at the politicians I look
at my fellow citizens and I ask how are
they thinking about this problem can I
help them improve or strengthen whatever
ideas they have but because then you can
base it in an objective reality rather
than what you feel needle should be true
right let's take a short break I want to
come back and talk to you about beauty
gender and race that should keep people
hanging on but also about space
exploration what do you think of it
welcome back to my special edition with
astrophysicist and author Neil deGrasse
Tyson His Brilliant new book Starry
Messenger Cosmic perspectives on
civilization is a much needed Clarion
call for a belief in science and facts
that old trick to try and get through
the world's complexities
um Neil let's talk gender is probably
the most divisive theme in the world
right now it's almost like you can't
even talk about it without people losing
their minds and I guess at the center of
it is this core belief which many but
forward that there is a biological
science towards sex and then there is
gender and that is an identity issue
which is separate to sex and biology
what is your view of this and why has it
got so toxic and what is the way through
this debate
yeah so I think I have some insights
there brought to you by how we end up
classifying things in the universe in
the universe very few things are
discrete in what they are there's in
almost all cases a Continuum between one
kind of object and another now it's hard
to have conversations about continua so
you you divide it up into as many
categories as is sensible and then you
then you
then you have a way to discuss what's
going on in the universe with others so
here we have human beings where let's go
back to the the bio part of this where
you have the chromosomes x x y there's
intersex where one of the chromosomes is
doubled up no one is arguing that just
give that to the biologists and you can
call that uh what sex is it male sex or
female sex I I don't have a problem with
that what I do know is that in the real
world in the real world in a free
country where because I remembered some
document that said the pursuit of
happiness
um it seems to me Freedom which is so
heavily championed in the west is
accompanied by a Pursuit of Happiness
okay
that's foundational to what I'm about to
say
so we all know growing up that in the
classroom every year there were girls
who were a little more tomboyish in fact
we probably tomboy who came up with that
word they're really Tom girls right a
tomcat is a boy cat a tom girl would be
a sort of a boy girl right I don't know
where tomboy came from but they were Tom
girls they didn't wear skirts they
wanted to play in the mud with the boys
we know they existed they were boys that
were slightly effeminate relative to the
others we know they existed and so but
we had words for them they were
ridiculed whatever we live in a time now
where people are emboldened to say you
know today I feel
part female and part male all right so
today in fact I will be neutral to you I
will be androgynous
but you know something if you're trained
in this you got to be a or b you got to
be a boy you got to be a girl you know
what you're doing you're taking your
inability of your human Mind by the way
this is true for all human Minds because
we got to categorize we always have to
categorize all right it makes it easier
to think about it but it the in the end
it's just lazy all right so you say boy
or girl are you a boy or a girl and then
someone is androgynous and it makes you
feel uncomfortable but just because you
feel uncomfortable does that give you
the right to come back to a person who's
expressing their freedom of self it
doesn't but I would say what I would say
right but what I would say to this
here's where it gets more complicated
take the issue of transgender athletes
in women's sport for example
okay no no I got two more sentences and
I'll jump right into that okay I just
want to set up to set the table here I'm
setting the table where okay that
if J if we allow gender to appear on a
spectrum gender expression to appear on
a spectrum
as is apparently the case in the real
world where people have the freedom to
do so
than for you to put your limited
capacity to think on a spectrum in a law
that inhibits the freedom of others
that's not a free country
okay so now take it to the next step
where do you want to take that well what
I want to take you to is I I don't
disagree with that I think in a free
country you should be allowed to
identify whatever you the hell you want
to identify as it's fine I've got no
problem with that okay so now where are
you taking it so what I'm taking it I'm
taking you specifically to say the issue
of transgender athletes in women's sport
which I think has in an attempt to
provide fairness and equality for Trans
athletes in women's sport it doesn't
apply the other way in Municipal in
women's sport it's created a new
inequality and unfairness where you have
trans women born with Superior powerful
male biological bodies who are beginning
to beat women with comfortable ease in
many sports and yet they were very
unsuccessful comparatively when they
competed against other biological males
as they were before they transitioned so
my my question I guess there is isn't
that a clear case where science has to
be the understanding Factor because if
you remove that from this equation then
you end up with gender-neutral Olympics
and women don't ever win Olympic medal
again
well there are certain events that the
men like like the uneven bars you won't
find men on the uneven parts that
doesn't work
okay uh but my point being there are
reasons why we divide the sexes in sport
is my point and the moment you start
allowing of gender identity to to
overcome biology I see there's a problem
Okay so
all that means is we are on a frontier
that has not been previously breached
which is what do you do in a sport where
now there's an inherent
um advantage or disadvantage based on
the rules that existed for that sport
whereas previously those advantages or
disadvantages didn't exist so this is
not complicated
in high school in college and a little
bit of graduate school
I wrestled okay I was Captain of my high
school wrestling team and undefeated
uh I weighed in high school 190 pounds
uh do I wrestle the 125 pounder no that
would be unfair because I'm 65 pounds
heavier twice as strong and maybe even
faster so they set up a rule I only
wrestle people my weight wrestling has
10 weight categories
to make it an interesting contest okay
so let me just make this up now just as
a as a starter point
uh the transgenderism usually involves
hormone uh readjustments okay
testosterone estrogen and so we can
imagine a future of sports where you're
not contesting men against women
you're contesting people in certain
brackets of hormone levels
and
why not because it doesn't work
I hesitate to lecture you about science
a professor Neil deGrasse Tyson I really
do but I'll tell you why not because
what they've they've already tried to do
this they've already tried to reduce
hormone levels what it doesn't do that
process is reduce body mass or strength
which comes from that's the next apology
right if you went through puberty as a
male yes and then transitioned
afterwards right then you you'll have a
bigger strong typically bigger strong
that's what I just think it's unpacked I
don't have a transphobic bone in mind
let's get there I'm getting there
for Trans athletes but there's a big
butt here I think I I
I'm working my way up to that so so one
possibility like I said I'm just making
this up on the supply is you have
hormone categories if that does not
solve the problem or to the extent that
it doesn't then you put in other rules
that separate who's competing with whom
like I said we do this all the time
right all right and by the way are you
going to go to Michael Phelps and say
you were genetically taller and we have
a floppier I don't know if all of this
is true but some of it is true you have
floppier ankles and webbed fingers and
so we're not going to compete you in
this race because you'll have an
advantage that other people don't we
don't do that do we in fact when you
really analyze it practically every gold
medal record-setting Olympic athlete has
some genetic thing going on in them that
other people they do but my response
okay my response to that would be I
think Serena Williams has been on record
as saying that she would lose to the top
1000 male real tennis players so my
point you could be you could be number
999 best in the world as a male tennis
player and become immediately if you
decided to identify as a woman the
greatest woman tennis player of all time
is that fair I don't think it is okay so
now watch so watch so it turns out if
and I've done this but others have done
it as well but I did it for myself to
know it if you look at world records
from world-class athletes uh let's say
track and field the 100 meters men are
about 10 times 10 faster uh 200 meters
10 it fluctuates but on average it's
about the marathon the men do it about
10 faster okay and you look at reflexes
it's about 10 percent faster the way you
have the biggest differences in
weightlifting but for Speed and reflexes
it's about 10 faster so if you wanted to
find out where the top women's athlete
would land among men you look at
serving speeds for example because
that's how fast you can bring the racket
to the ball and find the point where the
women's serving speeds match up with the
men's serving speeds okay and then
that's where you would land in the world
rankings what I will tell you is people
pay to watch sports not for how good the
athlete is they watch sports for how
good the contest is
but let's remind ourselves of this if if
we only watched Sports for the greatest
of athletes you would never watch
college football never because the the
worst NFL that National in the London
audience here National Football League
the worst National Football League team
there ever was
could wipe their ass with the best
college team there ever was right
because everyone in the professions each
one of them was the best in their
college okay so but we love watching
college football why because the contest
is equal and you don't know who's going
to win in advance if you was going to
win in advance you wouldn't that would
be that would be even if it was the best
to bring this this bit of the interview
to I think enclosure I would say I I get
that completely but the most important
thing as a sports fan is you want to get
a sense it's a fair playing field that I
think is really the Crux so what you do
is in in the future what you would do is
it so if the hormone levels categories
don't work then there are other
categories reflex categories okay have
people compete in reflex categories I
would love that okay then the people
with pretty slow reflexes they'll have a
different strategies and how they would
win and and group them together by the
way in chess tournaments your chess
rating
put you in a category where you only
compete with other people in that rating
you don't compete against people where
you beat them in 10 moves so so we are
still on at the dawn of how we will or
should organize the future of sports in
recognition of the gender spectrum and
we just have to put some creativity
behind it I don't see any problem with
it that's why I never wrestled 120 pound
person I would love to see that would
have been quite entertaining
now when we come back in the Octagon you
pay to see that I've actually seen some
very very skillful 120 pound wrestlers
it wouldn't be a given sometimes the big
guys go down even you Neil deGrasse
Dyson uh undefeated very impressive by
the way undefeated High School in high
school I want to come back I want to ask
you the 10 burning questions about the
universe that we reckon me and my team
uh are the ones that you probably get
asked more than any other rapid fire
instant analysis of all the problems
facing the universe only you can answer
welcome back to the final part of my
fascinating uh with author and
astrophysicist Neil deGrasse Tyson is an
electronic Cliffhanger the 10 burning
questions about the universe rapid fires
here we go what was there before the
beginning of the universe everyone asked
this question what's the simple answer
oh I I'm delighted I can respond to you
we don't know but we got top people
working on it okay you know what there
may have been a Multiverse I like that I
like the honesty so we genuinely don't
know people just don't know right
we don't know there might have been a
Multiverse that's birthing universes and
we're one of them but that just pushes
the question one step further before
that what was around before the
Multiverse so we just don't know it's a
frontier question right now how will the
universe end and what will there be
afterwards
we have several ideas for how it will
end one it will just continue to expand
forever as the temperature descends
asymptotically towards absolute zero and
all phenomenon and all processes will
cease All Stars will burn out they will
shut off in the night sky one by one and
the universe will be cold and dark
but if the expansion of the universe
which is rapid and accelerating is real
and continues that'll take us to the big
grip which we may have talked about on
Monday's visit that terrifies me because
if the fabric of the universe stretches
faster than the [ __ ] then the material
substance can sustain it then it rips
into the uh oh so that's in 22 bill
that's in 22 billion years
of that conversation was it takes 22
billion years to happen right will we in
the next hundred years live on the moon
or Mars or any other planet other than
planet Earth human beings
uh it's not that we can't do it not that
we couldn't figure out to do it we'd
have to ask what is your motivation to
do it do you realize Antarctica
is wetter and balmier than every spot on
Mars surface and you don't see people
lining up to build condos in Antarctica
so I can see them as tourist
destinations I'll totally take a tour to
and have maybe the moon Olympics that'd
be fun okay and a moon Chef's Chef's uh
shows but and the joke I always like
telling and it never gets old for me is
like the new cuisine on the moon and
restaurants would be great it's just
that they wouldn't have any atmosphere
hahaha
that's brilliantly terrible that joke
um is the universe infinite and if not
what's on the other side of it
so the observable universe has a
boundary it's not a physical boundary
it's a it's a it's a it's a consequence
of how fast a light travels and how old
the universe is so that sets a horizon a
ship at Sea there's a horizon is is this
is the ship captain saying
is this all there is or does this ocean
go on and they know from their
experience the ocean continues we're
pretty sure the Universe goes well
beyond our Horizon we don't know how far
and it's possibly infinite and if it is
infinite then it wouldn't make sense to
talk about an edge no then the second
question becomes Superfluous is time
travel possible
we can definitely travel into the future
by moving faster relative to everybody
else
um and then you'll come back less aged
than those you left here
tricky part
yeah the tricky part comes if you want
to go into the past and that's really
dangerous it is so dangerous that
Hawking was thinking to himself that
there must be some law of physics we
have yet to discover that prevents it
physically it's called a time travel
protection conjecture all right where
because if you go back and prevent your
parents from meeting each other then you
will never be born to go back in time to
prevent your parents from meeting each
other and this whole thing with the
Terminator movie where he's killing
everybody who might give birth to to the
whose person who's going to overthrow
the the regime all you have to do is
prevent people from meeting each other
or have them have sex 10 minutes later
or earlier than they might have
otherwise and a different sperm would
have fertilized the egg you got a
different person this won't shoot him it
was so needlessly violent
um so yeah it might not be likely that
we can do this but there are equations
in the general relativity that allow it
we just Hawking just wondered whether
we'll come up to a boundary a rule that
says nope nope the equation tells us but
a higher understanding of the universe
might actually prevent it
parallel universes do they exist
or our current understanding of how this
universe got here tells us there are
plenty of other universes and that's the
Multiverse idea and parallel universe
sounds a little more cool than just
other universes in a Multiverse but sure
then there's likely an infinite number
of them
hence the possibility that I'm
interviewing you on my show from London
and you're here in the you know all
combinations of all atoms and molecules
and thoughts and neurosynaptic firings
would exist in the infinite universes
that are out there you've actually
suggested it I think you suggested it's
just they could be a parallel universe
where dreams are reality and reality is
a dreams
yeah yeah or where stars are gazing down
at you rather than you casing up at the
start you can there's a lot of
variations in this and some of these
universes would have it slightly
different laws of physics so you don't
want to visit them without full
understanding of the consequences of
that you don't want to collapse into a
pile of goo because the molecular forces
that previously held your body together
in this universe don't work in the other
universe that would be a dangerous
dangerous freeways to take okay is there
anyone else out there professor
uh anyone you mean just life at all yes
probably we are made of the most common
ingredients in the universe hydrogen
oxygen nitrogen carbon iron this stuff
is everywhere in the universe life on
Earth was opportunistic it didn't take
the rare ingredients and figure out what
it could do the most common ingredients
and life started almost as quickly as it
possibly could have and we just one
planet out of eight get over it eight
planets and one star among hundreds of
billions in a galaxy among hundreds of
billions to suggest that we are alone in
the universe would be inexcusably
egocentric driven by some philosophy
that is not grounded in observational
science
what's inside a black hole
do you want to go find out oh no we
think we know what is the short answer
we don't have
okay okay
so we have our equations tell us what's
in a black hole but we've never tested
this just so you know so it tells us
that within a black hole the a whole new
space time can open up
in the future history of this universe
and for by that reasoning we in this
universe may be the other side of a
black hole that lives in somebody else's
universe so that is perhaps the most
intriguing part of the equations that
give us black holes what's the most
important thing that most of us don't
know about the universe that we should
for me it's the greatest gift that
modern astrophysics has given
civilization in 1957 a research paper
was published including a leading female
scientist by the way who's under
celebrated maybe one day we'll get a
good biographer for her name is Margaret
Burbidge but anyway they published a
paper
demonstrating that the that the atoms in
your body the nitrogen the iron the
carbon that all of this are traceable to
Cosmic crucibles deep in the centers of
stars it make it manufactures them by
thermonuclear Fusion the star explodes
gathers that enrichment into gas clouds
that make the next generation of star
systems such as we so it's not like
you're out in the universe looking up
and you say yeah I'm alive in this
universe but I feel small no the
universe is alive within you
and you should feel large
that Revelation that we are not
poetically but literally Stardust
borders on the spiritual and I think
everyone it's it is their duty to know
that to be honest that is very well
aware that I am Stardust for a long time
Professor just to clarify yeah
just don't sweep you into the dust bin
you know we just
throw away a final quick fire question
for you of the ten what is your favorite
fact about the universe of the
unbelievably large number of facts you
must have ascertained along with your
scientist colleagues what's the number
one fact that you love most
I am astonished
every day I wake up
that the universe
is knowable
even on the small scales that we've the
nuts that we've cracked for it that it's
knowable at all that we are just you
know billion year old carbon as as Joni
Mitchell puts in her song Woodstock we
can rise to Consciousness and pose
questions about our origin it's been
suggested that we are a way for the
universe to know itself
but the fact that the universe is
knowable at all to me
is stupefying because who said it had to
be that way that we measure laws on
Earth and they are the same as they are
in the heavens
it enables my profession in the first
place
but I'll end with this thought that as
the area of our knowledge grows
so too does the perimeter of our
ignorance
so this might be a never-ending Journey
so the more we know the more stupid we
get is that the bottom line
you got to say it more poetically than
that just
put it out there like that
Neil deGrasse Tyson what a what an
absolute pleasure to spend more time
with you the book Starry Messenger
Cosmic perspectives on civilization is
utterly rivety and hugely entertaining
as indeed are all interviews with you
thank you very much for joining Piers
Morgan unscented tonight
thanks beer
well that's it for me whatever you're up
to Keep It cosmically Uncensored good
night